girl Chrissy Teigen she made it a
mommy's night out for a great cause in
New York last night Chrissy telling us
that even the littlest legends are all
about paying it forward Lunas just
gotten into it starting to be able to
walk and actually like talk and vocalize
things language pinky three years old
and already running the household but
it's nice to know Luna and baby brother
miles are all about giving back in LA we
do a ton of donations she's excited to
be able to share her things with people
we caught up with Chrissy at the City
Harvest gala in the Big Apple last night
she co-hosted the event that benefits
New Yorkers in need of food Jon's
performed many times before I love being
here Chrissy even kept her cool when she
was heckled at the event by an anti fur
protest shame on you you heartless
murderer side note she wasn't even
wearing fur meanwhile Chrissy's usually
a favorite on the Met Gala red carpet
she skipped last year because she was
eight months pregnant so will we see her
Monday night I'm so sad I'm gonna miss
this one but I'll be watching for sure
stay home and take care of baby you know
what I didn't hear anything she was
saying cuz I was too busy thinking about
how all right so there is no Met Gala
for Chrissy this year that she's a
little bit busy was just announced that
who is gonna produce an upcoming food
focused project with her I know she's
been wanting a food show for a long time
oh yeah she can yeah
[Music]